[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
lori valodebel remains incompetent to
stand trial as chad dabel's children
claim he's been framed the latest on the
doomsday duo and our kelly's former
assistant testifies the singer would
dish out harsh punishments to his
girlfriends and employees plus the words
from the mother of college student molly
tibbetts to the man convicted of
murdering her daughter because of your
act mr rivera
i will never get to see my daughter
become a mother
and robert durst's eerie reaction when
confronted about dismembering his
neighbor the real estate era telling a
jury he drank a bottle of whiskey then
used saws and an axe to chop up morris
black's body
that is my testimony law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin doomsday mom lori valodebel
remains incompetent to stand trial for
now as her husband's children are
speaking out claiming he was framed but
first to r kelly's trial and the
stunning new allegations against the
singer
the fourth employee of the disgraced
king of r b testified in the ninth day
of r kelly's sex trafficking trial
describing kelly's harsh rules and
punishment as well as a time women were
punished for twerking for cake
suzette mayweather kelly's assistant
from october 2015 to february 2017
testified that on r kelly's january 4
2016 birthday party he ordered women to
get on each other or fight because he
did not like that they were twerking for
cake mayweather testified that while she
did not see any fights she did hear
laughing screaming and thumping from the
studio above
mayweather told the jury about her
former boss's anger and how he would
dish out punishment to employees and
girlfriends that she and kelly got into
such an argument about speaking with one
of his girlfriends about the
relationship something kelly forbade
that she lied about who started the
conversation out of fear of what would
happen to the girlfriend and then one of
kelly's girlfriends gave
came to her crying showing her a mark on
her butt from where
she claimed rob spanked her mayweather
corroborated kelly strick rules and
employees and girlfriends and said that
kelly got angry and it wasn't the tone
but the look in his eyes
joining us today is former prosecutor
melville pearson along with terry austin
melba what do you think of the order in
which the prosecution is presenting
witnesses how are they presenting the
case overall
i think they're doing a good job overall
i think that especially when you're
dealing with something that's so
sensitive you've got to grab the jury
right out the gate right it's that
theory of primacy and recency jurors
remember the first thing they hear and
the last thing they hear so it's really
important to put the two strongest parts
of your case in the beginning and in the
end to make sure you're holding the
juror's attention so by starting with
the survivors talking about what they
experienced now that laid the foundation
and then now the prosecution added
another layer with the employees that
are now corroborating everything that
the victim said so that emotional punch
is there and then now you have the
corroboration to really boost up the
truthfulness of what they're saying so i
think they're doing this in a good
fashion i'm very curious to see what
their recency is or the last part of
their case that they'll be presenting to
make sure that it's impactful so true
i've sat in the court for at least four
of the nine days i wish i could tell
show people what's happening but of
course we can't put videos in a federal
court system terry mayweather doesn't
seem to be part of the criminal
enterprise for the rico in charge so
what is your testimony giving to the
trial
well i do think mayweather is
contributing to the ricoh charge
remember the racketeering is an
enterprise here and one of the things
she said is that he angered easily that
he controlled the girls that he scared
them that he beat them until they
actually got scars on their you know
rears and so i definitely think that she
is showing that he is controlling all of
his employees to support this enterprise
and to support his brand
definitely a lot of corroborating
testimony there from a number of r
kelly's
employees will make sure to continue
with coverage of the usb r kelly trial
thank you both turning now to our other
top story the latest on the doomsday duo
chad dabel's children are now insisting
he's too smart to have buried his wife's
two children in his own backyard
chad bell is facing a slew of charges in
connection to the murder of his first
wife tammy dabal along with the murder
of j.j valo and tyler ryan the children
of his current wife lori valodebel lori
is also charged in the murders but is
deemed incompetent to stand trial for
now investigators have said the couple
was preparing for an end of the world
scenario and wanted to rid the world of
zombies and the human bodies they
inhabit now chad dabel's five children
are speaking out publicly revealing they
were told their mother tammy died from
asphyxiation in an interview with cbs's
48 hours chad's children say their
father was previously a gravedigger and
do not believe he is the one that buried
jj and tyler in shallow graves on his
own property
did your father chad debel play any role
in killing jj and tyler
no no it's something completely
unthinkable
how is it possible two children are
found buried in your father's backyard
and he had nothing to do with it
he was framed
attorneys for laurie vallo de bell
appeared in court virtually on monday
laurie debell is currently in a
psychiatric hospital and will remain
there until at least the next week when
the judge will decide if she'll remain
there for treatment
i wouldn't consider them a progress
report i think we need a progress report
before an order extending the commitment
would be entered so i was just asking
does the state agree that before
extension of a commitment we would need
to see the progress report to satisfy
the statute
yes we the state does agree all right uh
mr means mr archibald do you also wish
to have a progress report in hand before
the determination on a
extension of the commitment
yes your honor
yeah i don't think we could test the
idea of continued commitment but a
progress report i think would assist
with the matter of fall parties
terry based off of what chad davao's
children are now saying are you sensing
a new defense strategy
well i think it is slightly new here
initially it did seem as though chad was
going to say that they are both innocent
but i think he might be pointing the
finger at lori and even alex he could
very well say that lori was mentally ill
and she directed alex to kill the
children and of course we know alex died
in december 2019 and he cannot be tried
and if she's mentally ill
she will be protected for a certain
extent if the prosecution isn't able to
show that she had intent and so i think
it's a win-win for all of the defendants
if he sort of points the finger at alex
and lori and tries to say one was
mentally ill she didn't know what she
was doing the other is now gone and of
course i had nothing to do with it i
think that's a creative and interesting
defense one that i think i i think is
the only one that he can really argue
that might get it from out from under
this of course we'll continue to follow
that case as he stands trial on his own
and again lori valodebel is still
incompetent to stand trial at least for
now
still ahead on law and crime daily jury
selection begins in elizabeth holmes
federal fraud truck
plus a bottle of jack an axe and a bow
saw how robert durst explains he chopped
up his neighbor's body hear the real
estate's laugh when confronted with his
own testimony next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back the jury selection is now
underway in the highly anticipated trial
of elizabeth holmes the former therino
ceo accused of defrauding investors of
millions in scamming doctors and
patients
elizabeth holmes is facing 12 charges of
wire fraud and conspiracy to commit wire
fraud at our now defunct startup holmes
falsely promised that theranos developed
a blood test that only required a prick
of blood in newly unsealed court
documents holmes attorneys indicate
she's likely to take the stand in her
own defense and accuse her ex-boyfriend
and theranow ceo ramesh sunny bolwani of
psychological emotional and sexual abuse
attorneys will narrow down a pool of
nearly 200 prospective jurors to select
12 that will decide her fate
now to california for the trial of
robert durst and how apparently the next
key piece of evidence is a bottle of
jack daniel's whiskey
robert durst has been on the stand for
nearly three weeks proclaiming his
innocence and trying to explain what he
thinks happened to his best friend susan
berman durst is accused of killing
berman in their benedict cannon home in
december of 2000. previously durst was
on trial for killing his neighbor morris
black durst was acquitted for the murder
claiming self-defense but was found
guilty of dismembering him and dumping
him in galveston bay in previous
testimony durst explained that he drank
a large amount of whiskey before
chopping up morris black's body with an
axe and bone saw
mr durst
this is a fifth of jack daniels whiskey
correct
is that correct mr durst
so
examine it if you want take a look i
don't need to examine well this is a
fifth of jack daniels correct correct mr
durst is there any way are you telling
this jury that you believe you could
have ingested
that amount of liquor
and then
dismembered a corpse with saws and an
axe is that your testimony
that is my testimony
then lewin questioned him about the gun
and the many rounds of ammunition found
in durham's possession when he was
arrested for morris black's murder
winter said he was planning on killing
himself lewin quickly jumped to how that
didn't add up
you agree mr durst that what you did
have in the glove box was a fully loaded
38 correct
correct and mr durst you previously said
that you had this gun
because you were thinking about killing
yourself is that correct all right how
many rounds does it take for someone to
kill themselves
i don't know
you don't know no i don't know are you
aware mr doers to people killing
themselves by firing one shot into their
head
waiting while firing another shot did
you need 39 rounds of hollow point 38
ammo to kill yourself mr durst
no
so why did you have 40 rounds of ammo
minimum in that car i assume they came
with a gun
back with us is former prosecutor
melville pearson and terry austin
terry
what do you think the point of uh
challenging durst about whether or not
he drank a fifth of whiskey
here is the point and it's a good point
lewin is establishing the fact that all
durst does is lied whether or not it's
when he was interviewed with the
authorities or when he was interviewed
by jarecki or by lewin himself or even
the other day at trial lewin is trying
to say that you lie about everything so
he's trying to say there's no way you
could have had this whole bottle of
whiskey walked back and forth to your
apartment chopped up a body and still be
standing on your feet the best part of
that testimony though was that evil
laugh and i think the jury took note of
that
yeah definitely a laugh half of me
thought that durst was about to open up
the bottle of jack and sip it just to
make sure it wasn't another brown liquid
because that's definitely up durst alley
melba durst may not be off the stand
after the cross examination do you think
his lawyers will try to rehabilitate
what was said on i don't know redirect
i don't think they have a choice because
he came off so badly that they need to
do something to try to place in the
jurors minds that you know this is going
back to the thought of he's a feeble old
man he you know look at him does he look
like somebody that could you know murder
someone and you know that sort of thing
so i i think they're going to do their
best now do i think the redirect is
going to be effective no
because again we went way too far down
the rabbit hole with you know many of
his admissions and weird comments that
he made etcetera etcetera and then of
course that opens up the door to recross
which i'm sure a lewin will jump on with
uh with
all vigor and joy so you know i would
say for them short redirect two or three
questions and sit down yeah i don't
think any questioning of robert durst
will be short but melba i'm hoping that
your words reach someone with power to
make it short we'll see how that plays
out
coming up on law and crime daily how a
witness is prior drug use can be helped
for the defense for the arson trial but
first sentencing for the murder of
college student molly tibbetts how much
time her convicted killer will spend
behind bars after the break
[Music]
we're back the man convicted of
murdering iowa college student molly
tibbetts is sentenced but not before
hearing from tibbett's mother law and
crimes angenette levy has the story
molly tibbetts mother laura calderwood
wrote a letter to the court she chose
not to read it instead of victim's
advocate read it for her
molly was a young woman who simply
wanted to go for a quiet run on the
evening of july 18th
and you chose to violently and
statistically end that life molly
tibbetts mother laura calderwood sat in
the gallery as her words were read she
described how she told her family
including molly's grandmother that molly
was dead
judy truly believed her granddaughter
would be found alive
because who could harm such a beautiful
vibrant
young woman calderwood also described
what was taken from those who loved
molly
because of your act molly's father rob
will never get to walk his only daughter
down the aisle
because of your act mr rivera i will
never get to see my daughter become a
mother
investigators said bahina rivera led
them to a cornfield near brooklyn iowa
where molly's body was found under corn
stalks bahina rivera claimed at trial
that two masked men killed tibbetts and
forced him to drive to the cornfield
where he left her body but prosecutors
said bahina rivera confessed to arguing
with tibbetts hiding her body in the
field her blood found in the trunk of
his car
mr bohanna rivera is going to be
sentenced to life without the
possibility of parole
and i would tell the court that based
upon the facts and circumstances of this
case it is very well deserved molly
tibbetts was a beautiful young woman who
defense attorneys acknowledged was a
genuinely nice person who didn't have
problems with anyone
do you have anything you wish to say to
me prior to my announcing what i'm going
to do here today
no thank you
judge joel yates didn't have any
discretion in sentencing it was
mandatory that he received life without
parole mr bahina rivera
you
and you alone
forever changed the lives
of those who love molly tibbetts
judge yates's words were important
because at the end of the trial a woman
and an inmate came forward and said that
two other men admitted to killing mollie
tibbetts bahina rivera's attorneys used
that information to try to get a new
trial but judge yates denied that
request saying it simply didn't line up
with the evidence for law and crime
daily i'm angenette levy
when we come back did one of the victims
of this deadly house fire suspect
something was going on all along the
accused arson is on trial and why a
witness was asked to install security
cameras on one side of the house next
[Music]
welcome back an ohio man is now on trial
for the murders of nine people
prosecutors say he set deadly fires over
grudges towards his neighbors
stanley ford is accused of setting three
fires in his residential neighborhood in
akron ohio nine people were killed
including an entire family and their dog
if convicted ford could face the death
penalty ford originally stood trial last
march but a mistrial was declared due to
the pandemic the first fire was set to
the home of lindel lewis and gloria jean
hart in april 2016. the couple was
killed in the blaze months earlier lewis
hired his friend taryn sibley to install
security cameras sibley says lewis was
suspicious that his neighbor the
defendant broke a window pane to his
front door
he wanted me to install some security
cameras on his house where he watched
those cameras and what oh yeah yeah the
focus was the focus was just like
you know
all the damage to linda's house was
always on that right side of the house
it's that right front corner of the
porch and so
he wanted those he wanted he went three
cameras was to be facing that away
you said you heard some light grumbling
right the question is
the grumbling was between mr lindell
lewis and his neighbor all right the
person that you saw driving that's all
driving up and did you hear then mr
lindell say anything derogatory toward
that person oh yeah he said it but i
mean
he
i'm just asking you did he say something
dropped yes he did and could you tell us
what it is he said
i mean okay
i can't really remember i know it wasn't
i know it wasn't nice
things got heated on cross examination
when the defense asked sibley if he was
aware of the people living in the
victim's basement suffering from drug
addictions
the people that were down in there
but listen but i'm not telling you
nothing but i'm not
terence sibley look at me
sir
i'm speaking to you
when there's an objection you will not
answer
everything he said after the objection
is stricken from the record the jury is
ordered to disregard whatever mr sibley
was just saying is non-responsive
and come decide more
the witness admits he's spent time in
jail for drug charges the defense then
used his own personal knowledge to ask
him hypotheticals like if he believed
that those people living in the basement
could have owed their drug dealers big
bucks alluding that possibly the drug
dealers could have set fire on the house
drug dealers
sometimes will front people drugs
and they'll owe them
money correct yes
in other words the the addict sometimes
if they have a relationship with a drug
dealer they can try and get the drug
dealer to give them some upfront and
then they'll owe them some money correct
yes sir drug dealers don't take very
kindly to
not getting repaid is that fair
probably not
remember did the defense seem to make
any headway in the questioning if the
people who lived in the victim's
basement owed money to a drug dealer
i don't i don't think so from the
standpoint of there has been very clear
animosity between the neighbors
themselves and the defendant so
so suddenly like this drug dealer's
gonna enter the frame when there's been
a long-term
drama or beef between the two groups
that doesn't make sense that flies in
the face of common sense and whenever
you want to successfully persuade a jury
you've got to appeal to common sense
it's gotta make sense it's gotta pass
muster so they're i think the jury is
going to see this as a last-ditch
attempt to try to stir you know take
that that
that
that glare that gaze off of their client
and move it towards someone else
absolutely i think that i think they'll
see through it all right we'll see how
that plays out of course that seems to
be their strongest and only defense so
far terry ford has an interesting and
complicated pass with him facing the
death penalty do you think his checkered
pass could help or hurt him
i actually think his checkered past
could help him if in fact what his
defense is saying is true that he has
dementia and that he has brain injuries
then that could be viewed as
developmental disabilities and the us
supreme court has actually said that
someone who has a development disability
can't be sentenced to death so this
could actually help him yeah this might
be a sentencing issue rather than guilt
or phase thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you